- All right, we have
reached the end of the show
but there's just enough time
for one more story, y'all.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
Okay, so I love sharing new artists
and so does my music
director, Jason Halbert.
He introduced me to a
singer/songwriter named,
Aaliyah Sheffield who first got attention
during the pandemic.
Aaliyah uploaded videos of herself singing
which led to a recording contract.
This summer, she released an EP titled,
"These Songs are for Anyone Sick of Earth"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
which is awesome.
Say hi to Aaliyah Sheffield everybody.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
- What's up Aaliyah?
- Hi.
- Look at your setup, oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- So you took time to do music right?
During the pandemic, right?
- Yes, that's all I do.
- Yes.
Did you find yourself to be more inspired
during that time as well?
- Yeah, I think I was
more inspired to write.
With just a lot going on, and
instead of ranting online,
I ranted in songs and then
posted those online instead.
- Well, I love Aaliyah's lyrics.
So like this line, "I ate
one of your little friends.
I will key your car.
Put sugar in your tank.
Make you remember who
I am and who I ain't."
- Yes.
- If you wanna write a song for
me anytime, I would love it.
I was like...
- I would love to.
I love your voice.
You are amazing.
- So I would love to.
- Oh my gosh.
- Well, I feel like your
lyrics could go any way.
You could go R&B, you could go pop,
you could go country with those lines.
Like any of those ladies
would key your car
I think at one time.
Anyone from those genres, like, I love it.
Thank you so much for
just being inspiring.
We love to like, highlight artists
that maybe everybody
hasn't heard of quite yet.
So thank you so much Aaliyah
for joining us today.
I'm loving your post right now, right?
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
- Aaliyah Sheffield's EP,
"These Songs are for Anyone
Sick of Earth" is out now.
Y'all gotta check it out.
That title is incredible.
Alright everybody.
So usually at this moment in the show,
we give our guest a thousand dollars
courtesy of our season-long
partner Pilot pen,
makers of FriXion, the
go to a erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show".
But Aaliyah is skyrocketing to the top.
She's doing all right.
So today, it's going to be
someone in the audience.
(audience cheers)
So let's see who it is.
Again, look at the
monitor to see your face.
(audience continues
cheering and applauding)
Who's it gonna be?
(Shayla screams)
Hi.
- Oh my gosh.
Hi Kelly.
- [Kelly] Hello, what is your name?
- My name is Shayla.
- So Shayla, how do you think
you're gonna spend the money?
- I have loans to pay,
so that's the first thing
I need to cover.
- Okay, maybe take a
little bit and have fun.
Just like a tiny,
- carve a little piece.
- Just a little bit.
- Yeah, and I also booked a trip to Greece
for next year so...
- You're gonna love it.
- Yes.
- I love Greece.
- You're gonna love it.
Carve out some of that money for fun.
- [Shayla] Right, right.
- You know, be responsible
like, 85% of it.
- [Shayla] Right, I'll try to be.
- Exactly, exactly.
Well, thank you so much
Shayla, for coming.
I'm so glad you got a grand.
- Thank you Kelly, oh my goodness.
- All right, thank you to
all our guests this hour,
Bowen Yang, Tim, Juanita,
Jodie Long, Laura Terrell,
Emily Kaufman, (indistinct)
Good morning.
Y'all have a great day and
let's not try to change it.